[Music]
the least surprising news of the
millennium is that kim kardashian seems
to ruin marilyn monroe's iconic dress
this is before on the left
and on the right is what it now looks
like
apparently all sorts of stuff went wrong
with it when kim kardashian tried to
burst herself into it that's why she
should have never been allowed anywhere
near the damn thing um there we are
uh kim kardashian ruins popular culture
who knew sport washing what is it well
it's when a cold-shouldered
controversial country uses the prestige
and popularity of sport to whitewash its
ugly reputation the live golf series is
the latest sporting spectacle to face
the charge top stars have been offered
bottomless pits pots of saudi arabian
gold to join the breakaway league and
abandon the pga tour and to supporters
that's just business but to critics it
normalizes a saudi regime which uses
forced labor bombs children and yemen
and murders journalists so sport putting
money before morals well his golf
superstar rory mcilroy who spoke out
against the live golf invitational
series
i'm sure
not every saudi arabian is a bad person
and like it's it's very you know we're
talking about this in such a generalized
way and i've spent a lot of time in the
middle east and the vast majority of
people that i've met there are very very
nice people
but
there's bad people everywhere and
you know the bad people that came from
that part of the world did some
absolutely horrendous things
join me now one of the most experienced
premier league managers of all time
former tottenham west ham boss harry
redneck harry great to talk to you
peter's good talk to you
this sports washing um
what do we make of it i mean the
principle behind it is that these dodgy
regimes corrupt regimes that do terrible
things have appalling humans rights
records use sport by investing heavily
into the sports to try and improve their
image
what do you what do you feel about this
phenomenon we're seeing it more and more
known boxing and football and formula
one now in golf
i think it's been going on a long time
peers you know i mean we look we look
back to
you know people cleaned up their image
by buying football clubs coming to
england buying premier league clubs
it's something that's been going on
quite a while obviously with a saudi
situation and then the things that have
gone in their country
but you know they're coming they're now
owning a club in the premier league
newcastle and we can
you know we all feel strongly about the
things that have gone out going on in
that country but
you know you can't tell them geordi is
55 000 of them that turn up every week
to newcastle
they
you know they're not suddenly gonna stop
going and the players have been offered
enormous amounts of money to go on
playing this new golf
this new golf competition and golf tour
and they're going to take it i mean to
be honest they're not you know if
someone's coming off and i'm 50 60 100
million
to to go and play golf and where they
can treble their earnings
they're going to think well if i don't
do it somebody else should do it so
unfortunately that is the way to well
someone will come along and tomorrow and
say well you know do you want to come
out and work in saudi we'll give you 10
times what you're earning now it's very
difficult to turn it down i mean i think
my issue with it is there's a lot of
hypocrisy around this i mean take the
pga who runs the biggest golf tournament
in the world that the series everybody
wants to be on it but the pga did let
phil mickelson a number of the other
players on this live tour now they did
let them play in a saudi tournament last
year the deal was they then had to play
in the pebble beach pro-am once in the
next two years that says to me this is
not about morality
it's about money
yeah but it's all about money and it
really
everything is about money really appears
you know we've had the boxing going to
saudi we've had you know
as i say they're now coming the only
clubs in the premier league and
you know nobody really you know the
newcastle players will go over to saudi
for a visit with the management team and
you know
um as i say in the jewellery that them
great newcastle fans who love their club
every week they're not the slightest bit
bothered who's money as long as he's
buying they're buying better players
they're winning war games they're up the
league uh i've always said years ago if
saddam was saying that out of team
they'd all be singing there's only one
saddam the fans you know that is how it
is isn't it they're only intrigued they
give us a winning team we don't care
what you where your money come from how
many times have you seen it in this
country with people only buying sports
franchises who you know we all wonder
where their money's come from and
suddenly they changed their image they
cleaned their image up by i mean we saw
it we saw it with um
and he bought chelsea he gave him a
better image with the war in ukraine he
was unable to then denounce the war or
criticize putin because he would have
probably been killed by putin so he said
nothing and as a result he's lost it all
yeah i mean we don't actually know owns
off these premier league clubs anyway
really do we who you know we had people
you know i hear stories this guy who
owned one club he now owns another club
in england but he's not the chairman
because his money it's owned by the the
front man is somebody else they're all
you know they're using their money to
wash their money and um it's
so really it's we're not sure who's
actually behind after clubs in the
premier league i wouldn't think that
certainly a few of them anyway we've got
the world cup russian money and right
and i i totally agree with you we've got
the world cup coming in qatar and as a
result it's not this summer as it should
be it's going to be in in our winter
and my issue with that is i saw fifa for
example you know fifa's been all over
pride month and talking about it we
should be celebrating lgbt equality and
gay rights and so on and yet they've
sold their most prestigious
tournament the world cup to qatar where
it's illegal to be gay yeah there's a
lot of hypocrisy again there isn't that
absolutely well you know
listen we're not silly you're not you're
a clever man you know what what why is
it ended up there
you'd have to you know why have we ever
have had all these problems with set
blatter platini and all these people
it's all is it corruption harry playing
yeah of course yeah it's got to be in it
why they were they get why did they get
these tournaments you know you see the
russians you know you see putin with
johnny faint what's his name infantini
or what his name is
uh you know he's got getting him a
lovely nice uh
i don't know whether it was a gold watch
of what he was getting off him one day
but you know listen that's
that's that's that's how it works
unfortunately so we'll end up with with
tournaments
you know
in places like that because it because
it suits the people that make the
decisions yeah
harry a greater thoughty really
appreciate them it's a complex issue but
i think in the end you're right and i
think there's so much hypocrisy about
all this money will talk and the
hypocrites should yeah
sure hypocrites should take a back seat
great to talk to you harry
andrew pierce well done mate bye all the
best